Netflix's EXO kitties cast share their
favorite Korean dishes on the red carpet
so I'm gonna eat like them for the day
our Leading Lady Anna Cathcart says she
loves Chuck Bucky is one of my favorites
for sure spicy rice cakes and they're
everywhere in Korea like in the train
stations and on the street and wherever
so that's definitely a favorite it's
been years since I had this in Korea but
eating with a skewer or toothpick
definitely makes me feel like I'm back
in Guangdong market for lunch Gia Kim
who plays Yuri says that her at home
go-to is
soybean paste you it's easy to make I
never get tired of it it's healthy I
like mine super thick and stewy with
lots of veggies lastly our boys sang
unli and mignon Choi who play mindo and
they love Korean barbecue especially
pork belly barbecue sauce mignon also
likes beef so I threw in some brisket it
is shockingly easy to do a Korean
barbecue spread at home I got my sung
too or red leaf lettuce to make the
perfect Sam bite with a bit of rice my
crispy pork belly with samjong kimchi
roasted garlic and whatever pantan I
have this has been delicious and it's
been so fun to watch the mix of cultures
presented in EXO Kitty I'm already
waiting for season two